kristan Drummond is live on the strip
with more on which properties we'll be
welcoming back visitors Kristen Denis
some are key signs are already flashing
welcome back letting visitors know that
the strip plans to reopen after two
months of closures but not all resorts
plan to unlock the doors here's a look
at the map of the properties that
confirmed with us that they're returning
to business next Thursday it stretches
from the MGM Grand all the way up to the
strats so far those turning on the
lights plan to implement new safety and
health protocols those range from social
distancing to employees wearing masks
but not all who live in Las Vegas plan
to return so quickly I'll come down and
visit
I just just stick my head in and just
see how the new Vegas is but I won't
really be involved like I used to be you
know three months ago four months ago
the strip properties welcoming guests
plan to not only have gaming and lodging
but dining access to pools spas retail
as well as bars now it is important to
note that most properties are undergoing
a phased reopening so those will likely
be opening much later in a few months or
even later this year now governor steve
says alack says he is welcoming visitors
to come back again but he did mention he
is willing to pull back if there is a
spread of kovat at any of the gaming
properties but he is confident in the
precaution so far in place as outlined
by many of the resorts reporting live on
the strip Kristen Drummond 8 news now
Kristen thank you rounding out the hotel
reopening is Boyd gaming on June 4th it
will